the European Union the European
Parliament in Strasbourg has just voted
to approve a major changes to European
copyright law the proposal had moved a
tens of thousands of the Europeans to
protest against the measures they say
they were worried about how new rules
will affect a free speech on the
Internet at the heart of the matter is
article 13 of the legislation its
proponents claim it would help copyright
holders protect their intellectual
property but opponents fear it could
lead to censorship ldw correspondent
account matters is that the EU
Parliament in Strasbourg where the vote
took place welcome at Georg so talk us
through today's events a landmark
decision here really in the European
Parliament in Strasbourg it was a
nail-biter a bit off a bit unexpected
until the recent eruption of protests
against this law which is a law that has
already been agreed by the European
Commission it has been agreed by member
states and now it was up to the European
Parliament and a clear majority in
favour of making us tech joins in the
future legally liable for the content
they upload onto their platforms on
YouTube on Facebook you name it so now
in the future they will have to install
some filters which is a technical
solution so called upload filters and
that is a big concern for the opponents
of this reform I talked to two of them
just now at their very oh-so-close
matters in Strasbourg we'll leave it
there the technology having the failed
us so how exactly would article 13 it
changed the status quo on line now at
the moment if a user uploads text video
music or photos to our platform like
YouTube then the person is responsible
for respecting copyright restrictions
the changes the EU is now looking to
introduce that they make the platform
operators liable for the content and
this will be backed up with fines if
those laws are broken so it's meant to
force a sites like Facebook and YouTube
to monitor what users are actually
publishing critics of scale were saying
fear that websites will end up using
automatic filters that could also block
that is not restricted but as we heard
opponents of article 13 say that it
would have a chilling censorship effect
and small businesses so a gag matter sir
referred to his interview with one of
the laws main sponsors this was the
German MEP axel Foss and mr. Foss
rejected the criticisms that the bill
would stifle creating opportunities for
small startups and young internet
entrepreneurs so the youngest and the
smallest one they have excluded of these
for three years at the end but then also
you have to question yourself if your
business model is grounded on on
property or foreign creators and you
will earn lot of money with these then
you have to question your your own
business model if this is the right way
forward let's get more on this from
Teresa Locker she's a tech journalist
for motherboard Germany welcome Teresa
which side of this argument do you come
down on I tend to fall to the side of
the hundreds of thousands of people who
are protesting this reform / protesting
this reform because I fear there is a
chilling effect for the free flow of
information filters tend to over block
content and they also can't
differentiate between parodies remixes
and other completely legitimate uses of
copyright a big part of the the argument
against that which is at the moment you
can take someone else's copyrighted
material but there are certain ways that
you can use it for parody for instance
and you fear that that this would be
lost in this change yeah exactly for
example if you just talk about something
in a video you and you want to show what
you are talking about that would be
legitimate but with an upload folder you
can't even upload it so just to be clear
the law would not change that situation
because the law makes that exemption
you're saying that the technical fix for
this would be a problem
yeah the law is only to be implemented
with the technical solution that would
be an upload filter and that is the
problem so the law is the draft upload
filters no you can't have better upload
filters because you can't moderate or
filter all of the content that is being
uploaded to YouTube it's 400 hours per
hour material nonetheless it seems odd
in this day and technological age for
you to say that the upload filters that
we have now are the best that we can
ever have you you're saying that there's
no way that they can be improved well I
think that to reform the copyright is a
brilliant idea and it's much needed
because the law comes from a time where
there were no digital platforms
whatsoever but I think that to use the
material there should be a better idea
to use it in for example educational
contexts and parody contexts and remixes
in order to not hinder that free flow of
information that makes the internet so
dynamic how did you come back to this
because it seems to me that your
argument is not with the law but with
the way that the law is implemented
therefore should not your argument be
with the platform's the Facebook's and
YouTube's of this world rather than with
the European Parliament get better
solutions no there is no better
solutions because what happens now and
what will happen now is that YouTube and
yeah mostly YouTube they have to have
licenses with the entire world basically
and small platforms can't do that so in
a way this law is also strengthening the
power of the large platforms and is
hindering smaller platforms from just
disseminating information I wonder how
much of this this this argument is sort
of generational we've been talking about
it a lot in the office isn't pretty much
everyone over 40 thinks that this is a
good idea that people's copyright ideas
do need to be protected they're more
than 30 thinks this is a rubbish idea
because yes you need to do that but no
into the internet calculus I think of it
that way nowadays a lot of people are
content creators where are there is no
we in them it's not like we have
musicians and we have filmmakers and
we are only the consumers we who are on
the internet who participate in social
media we create content and so this law
is in the end hurting us all because the
technical solution that the platforms
are being forced to implement otherwise
they face fines is hindering to talk
about and to show the content that we
are all making and producing ourselves
so is there a better way that we could
achieve the aims that were that everyone
seems to be agreed need to be achieved
is there a better way to do it than
these upload filters yeah I think for
example a solution that is being used in
the u.s. fair use is pretty sensible for
the type of content and the type of
technology that we're all using it
grants the users and the consumers and
the upload is more rights to use a
particular copyrighted material if it is
to educate to display and to show in a
limited of time we'll see where this
will not go so having Theresa unlock
enough for now thank you